Mark s for the former U.S defense
secretary kind enough to join us
secretary he does raise a a good point
there the the hypocrisy in terms of who
we allow and don't allow into that body
but on this deal
um you're worried about what it could
spark that it might solve one hostage
set of swaps but encourage more right
well good morning Neil first of all but
look you're right it is it is a it is
not just a swap it is a ransom payment
if you look up the definition of a
ransom payment it is you know demand for
compensation or or payment in in
exchange for release of a person so that
is exactly what this is and
um you you got to get out of the mess if
you want of trying to discuss the
definition of what this is but any
reasonable person would conclude that uh
Tehran is going to learn from this
lesson that there is incentive to taking
more Americans wrongfully and using that
uh to get payments to get relief from
sanctions to get uh people who were
legally charged here in the United
States returned to Iran so it incense
all the wrong things that's why it's bad
policy you know um secretary I I can't
imagine that we offered a deal like this
to the Iranians and saying all right
this six billion bucks better be for
your humanitarian purposes and only
humanitarian purposes it would be like
me telling my son when he's at College
this money is not to go to any bars it
is not to go to you know any social life
fund it gets serious right
well I hope your son is listening to you
but uh who knows but you're right money
money is fungible uh the Iranians know
that we know it everybody knows that
that's why the Iranian president said
look it's their money and they're going
to do with what they what they will well
what do you think secretary I'm sorry
sir but to clarify that what do you
think they'll do with this money then
oh well I think they'll pump it into
their arms programs right they'll pump
it into the irgc the Iranian
revolutionary guards uh to uh either arm
themselves or to carry out their malign
activities throughout the Middle East
and elsewhere they could pump it into
their nuclear program so it comes back
as a as a means to fund illicit and
dangerous activities that we are trying
to safeguard ourselves and our allies
against in the region
so looking at this now of the secretary
I mean there are other hostages and in
other countries and in other dangerous
parts of the world we always run into
this Nothing is for free
um are you saying that if a republican
is elected president no matter who it is
that he or she should never entertain a
financial deal to get hostages out
generally no there are always exceptions
right there may be an extreme case so
you never want to take that off the
table but look I think we've come to
accept uncomfortably if you will
prisoner swaps right and typically
they're lopsided you look at the Victor
bout uh Brittany grinder swap you look
at this one you look at others typically
they release people who were wrongfully
detained or or charged on minor things
and we released people who are you know
uh International criminals or in the
case of these Iranians who are taking
American Technology back to Iran to put
in one case at least uh into their into
the technology so look I think swaps are
one thing uh they're uncomfortable but
what we tolerate it but I think when
you're talking about payments what we're
seeing now what we saw during the Obama
Administration where um you know pallets
of cash if you will were given to the
Iranians for the nuclear deal that that
just goes beyond the Pell and it becomes
payments that incent Iran and sent
Russia and sent North Korea and others
to take Americans uh hostage
secretary thank you very much very good
seeing you again uh it is very soon to
put it Miley hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else